boom what's up everyone welcome to
simulation I'm your host Alan sakyan
really excited to still be at American
anthropological association's annual
meeting we are now sitting down with Dr
Alex Barker thank you for coming on to
the show my pleasure really appreciate
it and I'm very happy because we have a
lot to talk about this is the first time
we're sitting down with someone that is
actually curating archeology and
anthropology at museums and art so this
is going to be I'm really excited so
your your background's awesome I want to
teach everyone about your background
you're the currently the president of
the executive board at AAA also got the
PHD in anthropological archeology at
University of Michigan and he was former
curator of archeology and anthropology
at the Milwaukee Public Museum for about
six years or so and then now as the
Director of the Museum of Art and
Archeology and also the director of the
Museum of anthropology at the University
of Missouri Columbia and that's been for
the last 12 years and three years
respectively so wow okay cool how did
before we get into you know what it's
like to even curate
um archeology artifacts as well as our
anthropological art and whatnot
um how did you how did you as a kid get
involved in anthropology
when I was about 14 I started
volunteering at the Milwaukee Public
Museum
and I volunteered in the anthropology
section with a woman named Nancy Lurie
who went on to become the president of
the American anthropological Association
whoa and shortly after I started
volunteering
some folks came in and did a program
about archeology in Southern Illinois
and they were the old Northwestern
program and they allowed high school
students to come in and do field
projects and I snuck in before I was
actually in high school and did my first
series of excavations in the middle
1970s but while I was still a before I
even got to undergraduate and I'd done
three years of excavations before I
started college
three years of excavations pre-college
yep whoa It's about time I got to
college I pretty much knew what I wanted
to do yeah okay whoa okay so this is
this is crucial because this is starting
to really uh continue this this
um
this really dire need that we have for
for you for youth for children for kids
to have some sort of mentorship within
their Opera the equality of opportunity
for them to find what they love and then
to have that mentorship you you were 14
when you started
um being able to have this access to
archeology as something that you cared
about now where did you go for three
years to to dig well the first two years
was in a little town called campsville
Illinois
which is a tiny little River Town
there's not much there besides the ferry
but the old Northwestern program under
Stuart streever had developed a whole
series of excavations at Major sites
ranging from archaic sites through Lake
Woodland into Mississippian sites in the
Illinois River Valley and mainly in
Macoupin Calhoun counties and so there
were different projects going on with
different Crews but there was this odd
period there in the late 1970s in
particular when it seemed like everybody
who's doing American archeology was
working at Coster or at Macoupin or at
worthy American or one of the other
sites based out of campsville at one
time or another so it was a very magical
time why I can go back and look at
colleagues years afterwards and we
compare when we cross paths and why in
the late 1970s was there a lot of
archaeologists in that area but it's a
Heyday of what's been called the new
archeology so it is a period when people
were moving from more normative
approaches to culture history to looking
at more scientific issues of process and
we've moved a little bit beyond that
since then but at the time they were
really heady days where there was a
sense that we were transforming the
discipline and The Way We Were
approaching ancient cultures was
fundamentally different than the way
we've done things before
there were some problems with that
approach and and it's been Revisited
since but at the time it seemed like a
revolution and revolutionaries have a
lot of zeal and energy and Stu straper
was one of the leaders of that movement
and what was Stu's kind of big thesis
around the movement
well there were a whole series of folks
who founded the new archeology and I'm
not going to get into all their names
but their approach was really that if
you looked at questions of culture
process and culture history you could
treat it as any other science and ask
broader more nomathetic questions about
why something happens you might be able
to develop predictive models that say
that under these conditions this is a
way of culture as a series of processes
would respond looking at systems theory
and feedback loops mainly in terms of
environmental issues because they're
easier for us to capture with archeology
it's harder to capture ideology we can
talk about it but it's tougher to
measure and tougher to assess but
responses to environmental changes
that's something we can get to pretty
easily and this is especially through
assessing artifacts for like carbon
dating things like that or is that
that's way better or is that like that's
yeah that's well partly for dating but
the other some of the techniques that
were really important during that period
it's the period when we first started
doing something called flotation on a
large scale which is when you take
samples of soil from an archaeological
site you float them using either water
or different chemicals and it allows you
to capture the light fraction of
material
charcoal plant residues things like that
and analyze them separately and you
capture not just what you were able to
see and collect by hand but everything
that was there in that sample of soil
and a heavy fraction that includes the
archaeological material Bones from
animals Micro flakes things like that
it was always there but in in periods
before that it was more common that you
just collect the things you could easily
see
and this was really looking at a much
finer scale of information like soil
compositions right the the tiny things
that are left behind so instead of just
thinking in terms of larger
artifacts or objects like a deer scapula
you look at all the fish scales and you
get a much finer grained idea of how
people were actually living and fine
scale changes as you move up and down
the stratigraphic column and over time
whoa and what were you know even before
we keep going I'm just so interesting
now because you're the first person now
that's that's taught me about how you
can analyze you know things like soil
composition or some of the things that
are not larger artifacts so what were
some of the profound realizations from
from doing so
oh just a complete change in our
understanding of the economics of some
of those prehistoric societies we'd
focused on them in terms of gross
indicators that were easy to observe
when you actually looked at things in
detail it was very clear that a lot of
smaller kinds of organisms were being
used it wasn't all deer it was small
animals and fish things that are harder
to see it was also going from imagining
that a lot of prehistoric societies were
using a single crop like Maize to
understanding how complex their diet
really was and moving from Wild
resources were being collected to
domesticated crops and back and forth
over time there's a much more complex
Mosaic of how people were living than
we'd imagined originally cool that was
in the 70s and since then instead of
just looking at fine things we're also
looking at the chemical composition so
you're able to say all right people are
changing their diet we're not just
finding artifacts or Equifax we're
looking at the actual bones of people
and or or sometimes it's not even the
bones of people maybe the bones of the
animals they ate yes and getting a
better sense for the environment from
that by looking at levels of strontium
or carbon isotope levels we get a much
clearer idea of what the environment
looked like yeah and all of that's just
in terms of the environment you can
still look at all sorts of other
questions archaeologically but our
ability to trace some of those patterns
over time has gotten steadily better
with time
I've really enjoyed the way that you
Illustrated it as a mosaic a complicated
Mosaic of of of anthropology and
Archeology of how they lived
that's a great way to put it and I think
we're too often thinking in large
artifacts and to infrequently looking at
those other complicated nuances that are
sometimes so small as like you do
flotation in order to figure figure the
composition out
whoa another area that really took off
during that period was archaeometry so
you might have a piece of stone you can
do the chemical composition of that
piece of stone or a piece of pottery and
get an idea for exactly where it might
have come from then you can start
tracing trade patterns over time
that's still within archeology within
the broader field of anthropology the
other thing has really changed is 25 30
years ago we would have thought in terms
of well we can analyze human bones and
learn these things
now there's much greater sensitivity
than there was a quarter of a century
ago to the idea that before we do that
we really have to talk to descendant
communities and find out if these are
questions they're comfortable with us
asking and whether these remains are
appropriate for that kind of testing
oh yeah oh interesting so you need to
get permission to test remains
in most free science yeah yeah
interesting and it's not simply a matter
of getting permission it's recognizing
that there are multiple constituencies
and multiple stakeholders involved in
the things we study yeah and we have to
work with those stakeholders and be
sensitive to their concerns yes yes whoa
okay that's a great way to to kick us
off now now what is it like to to go
through a okay you're now so now you you
end up you figure it out you're like
okay I'm ex I'm gonna I'm gonna I'm
gonna enter into school with a passion
for archeology and anthropology and then
um and then how did it look like till
you're you know to figure out what you
wanted to do for your thesis along that
Journey
there's so much to learn and right yeah
so how do you pick well that was a
problem I think like most people I went
through a series of different ideas and
in some ways what ended up happening was
I had an idea I started pursuing it and
then I discovered there were certain
things I couldn't do and so I had to
adapt what I was studying to the
material I was collecting my original
idea was that
sometime around oh 700 800 A.D in the
Lower Mississippi Valley you get the
emergence of societies that look more
complex they're building large Mound
sites they've got much larger
settlements scattered across the river
valleys but they're taking off before we
get the Advent of maize so corn
agriculture doesn't seem to have come in
yet we're not seeing the full
development of what later becomes known
as Mississippian Society
but there are very large settlements
large mound building communities and it
wasn't altogether clear what they were
how they developed and why they don't
develop into something even larger and
more complex over time so it looked like
they were developing and then collapsing
and developing and collapsing and I was
interested in trying to understand that
cycle of development and collapse
and then that there's would what were
some of the findings is it was it about
some of the power dynamics that caused
them to rise and collapse
well in at least in my analysis there's
a very gross analysis compared to what
we do today that was 20 some years ago
but at the time it was looking at
factors of the scale of settlement
and trying to measure by modeling how
much wealth was flowing back and forth
between communities so if you imagine
that these are hierarchical societies
there are some communities that are
producing more wealth and it's flowing
up the hierarchy
and there are ways to mathematically
model how much wealth is Flowing from
one Community to another at least
theoretically based on on how rich the
environmental Zone a given site is in
and how big it is yeah so if you imagine
that everybody's a
just eating what they consume
over time the size of a settlement will
grow and not exceed the size of the
catchment area the amount of food it can
produce and yet
we see again and again what appear to be
communities that are larger than they
should be given that measure and the
suggestion was made many years ago that
this is because they're gaining food
from other communities they're getting
resources from other communities and so
I simply modeled that for this period
and what you see is a series of
growth and collapse Curves in What's
called the Coles Creek period and in
trying to understand that I also
measured what would happen if
you assume that the reason that's
happening is that these early leaders
who are performing multi-community
polities if you assume that one of the
things they're doing is that in bad
times they provide relief they move food
back and forth
and if that's happening what's the
effect
at the same time there are models that
have been in existence since the 1930s
for how a given household decides how
much food they should grow
and when you put those two models
together you get a weird effect
which is that everybody's better off if
you move food around and help people in
harder times but the more you do that
the margins of surplus that are being
produced by each household go down and
so over time the system which is a very
good system collapses it just can't
sustain that because you're depending on
producing a surplus and that Surplus is
actually being reduced over time
okay whoa so okay so it's even more
boring in the original than it is when I
try to describe it
so let's see if let's see if I can uh
let's see if I'm if I can I guess uh
synthesizer further unpack this in a way
that you say is is
is is right now a society can be
positioned in a resource-rich area where
they may not be positioned in a research
resource-rich area and that is a that's
a one of the variables to calculate of
how wealthy they may end up being is how
much abundance they may have how much
Surplus they may get they may be
positioned near a water like a river and
that gives them easier access to travel
to transit to the other areas for trade
and so so then
the way that that that
group evolves or that that Society
evolves is different than one that was
in a resource not as resource-rich
veneria and then you were also
mentioning the
the dynamic of of certain people
producing some Surplus and then other
and then that Surplus decreasing so that
they can help people in need in that in
their society well you can imagine that
visually if you imagine a graph that has
one axis that's how productive that the
area of a site is and the other is how
big the site is okay you would expect to
see a more or less linear relationship
okay yeah yeah you have smaller sites
and areas that aren't very productive
and larger sites and areas that are more
productive huh when you actually graph
that out for these societies you get a
series of lines one above the other yeah
and the explanation that we believed at
the time at least was that it's because
you have some Villages that are
producing food some Villages have people
who are being supported by everyone else
yes and they're larger than you'd expect
those villages to be based on how
productive they are
oh and you're able to model how much
wealth of whatever kind is Flowing from
one set of communities to another set of
communities and in these cases you'd
have two or even three tiers in that
line okay so so
um so then a
a society that has more people that are
needing assistance of those that are
making the Surplus their productivity
line is a little bit lower it doesn't
rock it up as as much they're they're
less they take up more floor space or
more societal space they're a larger
society but they're not as productive
because there's more people relying on
the Surplus I wouldn't put it that way
I'd say instead that you've got some
some communities some individual
settlements have people who aren't
producing their own food it's being
contributed by other folks so the
settlement gets bigger than you'd expect
based on how productive productive it is
okay so then they they're consuming more
they're consider their settlement that
is receiving trade from another location
and they're not yeah they're not
producing themselves they're consuming
from they're relying so they're in a
non-resource or less resource-rich area
which is maybe one of the reasons why
there are more people that's so this is
so complicated one of my colleagues a
guy named stepinitis had observed that
he'd observed these patterns from
earlier research and he was able to come
up with mathematical models that let me
calculate how much wealth was flowing
between the different levels that you
were able to see those different lines
oh and so that's what I used yeah on the
flip side since the 1930s there was a
theory Advanced by a guy named AV
chinaov that said that if you're in a
house if you're a household in a
non-cash economy
you can't always convert the Surplus you
produce into more wealth there's a limit
to what you can do if you can't convert
it to cash if you yeah because you could
just sit on that resource without being
able to distribute it to anybody yeah
yeah and so there's a
the utility of the amount you're
producing at some point intersects with
the drudgery of producing it that's
right and like even here with there's
like extra food from some of the
engagements and and the extra food is
not being brought to those in need and
it can go it's it's an extra it's a big
issue with with extra food production
and homelessness what we see in San
Francisco and all these other places
because it becomes more of a drudgery to
go and move the extra food to the
location where the homeless are
um then so then you just toss it it
becomes the utility is isn't is God it's
a diminished well if you can't convert
it into something else you may not just
may not produce it but
those two systems are in conflict
because a system that
where you're extracting food from one
level of society to support another
level of society and that's justified in
part by the fact that by producing that
extra food you can move it around in
time of need so people don't starve
but if you're not going to produce it in
the first place because it's not worth
it and you can get the food from other
sources then over time that Surplus
decreases so you become more and more
dependent on a resource it's becoming
scarcerer and scarcer then the system
collapses and then reforms and does it
all over again
now
since then I would say there are some
problems with that model but that's what
I came up with at the time
whoa okay that's so in that this is this
is really cool Alex
um it's probably
um
understanding how civilizations
flourish and how they fall is probably
one of the coolest
things about anthropology
um okay let's um
let's move into how to was it the
Milwaukee Public Museum that you first
were injured when you were 14 as well
yes it was that okay so now you ended up
going back to to do the curation of the
archeology Okay cool so yeah how did uh
how did that happen well before I finish
my dissertation I was hired by the
Dallas Museum of Natural History and I
spent about seven years in Dallas
toward the end of that period I started
out as a curator then I became the chief
curator and then I served as interim
director for a while and at the end of
that period the museum was going through
a transition and they really wanted to
focus more on dinosaurs anthropologists
don't do dinosaurs so paleo
paleontologists paleontology and we do
early humans they may be fossil but if
Dinosaurs Aren't what anthropologists do
so I was looking for other opportunities
and at the same time my predecessor at
Milwaukee a woman named Ann McMullen had
moved on to the national museum of the
American Indian and Ann was a fantastic
curator but she contacted me and said
the position that Milwaukee was coming
open and for me it was coming home so I
was very excited about it and I was
lucky enough to be able to go to
Milwaukee and I was very happy there
and so what was it like because you
gained seven years of experience in
Dallas and then you brought that to
Milwaukee which was great so like what
were these first sort of
experiences as a director uh and
understanding like which artifacts do I
bring into which exhibits and what does
how does that work
well it's complicated in part because
the director really doesn't decide those
things it's always a group that decides
it okay and ideally it's a group that
reflects not only the professional staff
of the museum but the larger community
and so it's a negotiation that goes on
it's always trying to balance the
interests of the community what you've
done recently so you're not just
repeating yourself if there are hot
topics and issues you'd like to address
you want to bring in exhibitions that
can do that and at the same time you've
got this background going on of
processing objects that are coming in
from the field or that are being brought
in through donations and they may not
match up with the exhibitions you're
trying to do so you've got to do all of
those things
plus there are always opportunities that
come up we have a project going on right
now at the Museum of Art and Archeology
that has to do with the trafficking of
culture especially Antiquities that
oftentimes enter the illegal market so
Source countries like Italy Egypt Greece
are always facing a problem with looting
and objects being transferred out of the
country illegally whoa at the same time
they've got this huge backlog of
Antiquities that have never been studied
so yeah over time we were able to
develop a relationship with the capital
line Museum in our own when Rome became
the federal capital of Italy in 1871
they cleared large parts of the city to
build new buildings for the national
capital and they encountered all these
Antiquities from ancient Rome that have
never been studied they've been in a
warehouse called the antiquarium in
downtown Rome ever since and they've
never been analyzed
so we're now in a series of loans where
they'll send us Antiquities that haven't
previously been studied we analyzed them
we do archaeometric research to figure
out where they came from we do high
resolution scanning of them in
three-dimensional Imaging we study them
formally to figure out based on our
historical information when they were
produced where they were produced
compare that with the analytical results
and then we send them back to Rome and
they send us another group of objects
and we do the same thing over again and
over time the idea is to remove that
backlog of unspeed Antiquities yeah
wow okay so there's a couple things
there the first thing you said that was
cool was that
that it's not it's not even just a group
of curators at the Museum but you have
you deal with the community's interests
as well right so then you guys have a
kind of like a back and forth about what
you want to feature in as exhibits and
then
that was really interesting that you
bring up this this a backlog of
artifacts that need to be uh that need
archaeometrically analyzed they need or
just just to be documented so don't we
know it's there yeah Antiquities
trafficking is a huge problem yes
they're at different times and and this
is a controversial statement because
it's hard to really get a firm figure on
it but at one point Interpol said that
Antiquities trafficking is the third or
fourth most lucrative form of crime
worldwide that it lags behind drug
trafficking and arms trafficking and God
knows what to do with human trafficking
yeah but beyond that Antiquities
trafficking and art theft is a huge
business yeah in some cases the markup
between the amount that's paid for an
object that's looted what what the
looter himself would get or herself
would get and the amount that it sells
for on the market can be in the millions
of percent yeah
and
it's exploitative it destroys the
culture history of an area it robs
people of their Heritage and by doing
that part of their identity but at the
same time it's hard to combat when
there's that much money involved yeah so
there are a series of different
initiatives all around the globe trying
to stem the trafficking of Antiquities
part of it involves
enforcement of regulations and laws
prohibiting that kind of looting and the
movement of those objects part of it is
increasing the flow of Antiquities in
the illicit Market not necessarily for
sale but at the Capitol line for example
all of those objects were documenting
can now be used and loaned to museums
around the world that can be used in
programs they become available for
broader use now that they've been
documented yeah until then nobody knows
what they are and so they can't be used
yeah yeah
whoa thank you for bringing Antiquities
trafficking to our our
Spotlight here because that's
huge and I don't think we talk I don't
think we have we haven't talked about
that on the show yet that's that's a
huge one wow
um but it's also become huge in the in
recent years up until maybe a decade ago
there were very few prosecutions for
Antiquities trafficking because it was
felt to be white collar crime or there
were very few real victims in the past
few years it has been an understanding
that
looting and the destruction of Heritage
is also involved with trying to control
people's identity oh yeah and so it's
become much more of a big deal even for
the US government yeah the the
destruction of Antiquities by ISIS or
isil or daesh yeah whatever you want to
call it
brought to the fore of the fact that you
can manipulate people's understanding of
who they are Yeah by changing their
Heritage or taking their Heritage away
so it's become a broad and very complex
issue because on the one hand the US
government now views this as
geopolitical and a security concern yeah
that's not our concern as
anthropologists Our concern is much more
immediate that the Heritage itself
should be preserved preserved yeah but
there's an overlap there is yes
if you if you successfully wipe out
artifacts of a population you can make
it look like that population didn't
exist and then that that that can alter
the way we perceive history and then
that yeah that it's really important to
document now can you tell us the
teachers about these processes that you
were talking about so you you when you
receive one of the backlogged artifacts
from around the world which is it's it's
so interesting that there is a backlog
that needs to be documented like you
were saying that's so cool and we need
more archaeologists than to process this
and document this this backlog so you'll
get you'll get like a shipment in of of
artifacts and then now you were saying
like 3D scanning and um um our our
archaeometrics this is very interesting
so like what yeah what does that process
look like well the objects come in we
may get a couple hundred objects at a
time
we document the music art historical
techniques there are Styles and and
makers marks and other things that have
been documented through several
centuries of research now and we're able
to get an idea of what the material is
and when it dates to based on that art
historical analysis so that's the first
step the next step is we're able to take
chemical samples from those objects and
then analyze them mainly using Neutron
activation analysis Neutron activation
analysis yeah we use a reactor
by you're measuring the Backscatter of
elements and you're able to tell what
the chemicals are that are actually
present in that material okay and by
doing that you can get the recipe for
the clay well you're trying to find the
neutron as in the atom in the
that's what we're using yes yeah and
what we're really measuring in the
elements that are present in the
Ceramics interesting then you're able to
compare that recipe to the recipe of
Ceramics made from other places okay and
by doing that we can trace where the
Ceramics were made so for example in the
most recent batch of artifacts we've
been working with there are three
distinct areas where Roman black gloss
Ceramics were being made or at least
three different recipes for the clay and
we're able to trace those in the next
group we'll be looking to see if those
same recipes are being used if they
change over time or in different
locations or if they're a different
additional sources that are being used
but at this point we don't know so
that's the next step after that we start
doing three-dimensional scanning both
very high resolution blue light Fringe
well
a very high resolution scanning that's
at a good enough scale that we can do
things like look at the scratches on the
bottom of a pot to figure out how it is
being used so one of my colleagues
Marcella majetta from the University of
Missouri is leading a project looking at
the use where at the bottom of the pots
to figure out how they're being used and
what are the different ways that they
can be used well some of them are simply
included in burials so they may not be
used very much at all others have been
used on a daily basis and they've got
heavy evidence of wear both on the
outside of the vessel and on the inside
from stirring or from cleaning or from
all sorts of other things but he's able
to actually document those yeah yeah
which requires a fairly high resolution
kind of scan we're also using something
called reflectance transformation
Imaging which is a marvelous technique
it's one of those Innovative techniques
that you really wish you thought of
because it's so simple you take an
object you put it in a hemispherical
dome that has lights scattered all
around it then you take your series of
digital photographs and each photograph
has liked from a different Source yes
yes then all you do is interpolate that
using software and you're able to create
using exactly the same technique you use
in a movie like Shrek whereas Shrek
moves through through the the film
landscape the Shadows change yeah and it
looks very realistic this does the
reverse it says that if I'm seeing these
Shadows what's the surface look like and
they're able to mathematically calculate
what the surface looks like of the
object from the Shadows cast from all of
those different sources of light
not only does that give you what the
surface looks like but it also means
afterwards after it's gone back to Italy
and it's back in a storehouse in our own
you can look on your computer and move
that light source around and get raking
light across that object of small
different dimensions yeah and what's
wonderful about that is many of these
objects have Maker's Marks on them
excuse me and a Maker's Mark is the
maker who has a signature a trace stamp
stamp yeah and over time if you look
very carefully we're able to not only
see what the Maker's Mark is but we can
see it wear over time so as an early use
of the stamp for ladies
whoa
there's see yeah just just imagining you
receiving a batch of artifacts and and
going through all of this process and
then the nice thing like you said is
when not only is it the nice thing that
when it goes back you it's all
documented
is that a decentralized documentation
can anyone from around the world come
and get that that light scan the Shadows
yeah sure and in fact the project that
Marcelo is leading it involves folks
from
four different countries already and the
material is broadly available and the
metadata for it is actually being stored
not only by the Italians using their own
system for storing metadata but it's
also being served up in the University
of South Florida with your colleague
Rachel Lopez
on this like long-term civilizational
Evolution there's like a point of of of
humanity realizing that
oh crap like we should document what has
happened
oh that's good I'm not sure we're there
yet
yeah yeah you're right you're right
we're I'm not sure we're there yet
either but it seems to be coming
pressing even though there's so much of
the digital age is distracting us
towards what
this this the cycle of information is so
it just it's gravitating us towards
what's happening every single day even
though what has happened in the past has
yet to be so thoroughly documented and
understood we just keep living in the
next day on this on this news feeds and
dang oh it's a huge problem for
anthropology in general because if you
think of archeology as nothing but the
anthropology of the past so all the
questions we ask is anthropologists
archaeologists just translate those into
a thousand or two thousand years ago and
ask the same things and it is incredibly
complex to try to understand human
behavior in the present when you add the
fact that we're not able to observe it
directly we have to infer it from other
things when you get to archeology it
just adds into layer of complexity yeah
how many artifacts before before we get
to the University of Missouri Columbia
what um give us an idea of how many
artifacts approximately across the world
you think are still undocumented and
which cultures have the most I I
couldn't even guess yeah yeah the number
is is staggering it's like trillions I'm
sure it is yes yeah I mean every culture
that ever existed on Earth produced
objects yeah
not all of them survive to the present
but a lot of them do in some cases we
don't even recognize them yet because we
don't have the right tools but
the number of sites that are unknown is
unknown we know the rate of Destruction
to some degree and the rates of
Destruction have been skyrocketing so we
have this resource of unknown scale and
all we know is that is being destroyed
at an accelerating rate but how much is
left we have no way to tell and which
cultures would you say have the most
undocumented artifacts I don't we don't
know you were saying that like there's a
big backlog in Greece in Italy and
whatnot
so so there is a big backlog in certain
uh
cultures and then yeah okay yeah areas
where there's been a lot of
archaeological work done there may there
may often have been more archaeological
excavation than there has been analysis
by the way that's true of the us as well
we have a big curation crisis where
there are huge collections that may be
documented in the sense we know they
exist but they've never been adequately
studied
the problem in the other source
countries isn't that they've got a
problem that's fundamentally different
than ours it's that there's not as much
looting for international trade going on
in those other countries there's a lot
of it in some of those Source countries
and it's not just Greece Italy Egypt
it's also places like Cambodia it's the
Niger Delta there are a lot of places
around the world where the scale of
looting is incredible estimates say that
that probably 90 percent of the sites in
the Niger Delta have already been looted
oh my God and it's a guesstimate because
we have no way to estimate sites that we
haven't seen before
but if there's a site and We Know It
exists it's almost certainly looted
there may be sites we haven't found yet
but for the sites that are known almost
all of them have been deleted now before
we forget this question because I want
to hear your opinion on it
what are your do do most of the
Antiquity stuffs go to private
Collections and what do you think about
private collections versus public
collections
that's a very difficult thing to answer
a lot of them where it's obviously been
looted are going to private collections
or to unscrupulous museums there are
still museums that acquired Antiquities
that have been looted
the current guidelines and standards
prohibit that
and they usually require that museums be
able to find the provenance of an object
back to at least 1970 which is the date
that UNESCO passed a convention on the
trade of of Antiquities and so the
current guidelines say that it needs to
have left its country of origin by 1970.
and if it didn't leave before then
the likelihood that it's generating more
looting because it's coming from sites
that are still being looted or
that
the circulation of that object buying
and selling that object is likely to
contribute to ongoing looting is much
higher if something came out of the
ground in 1800
it may be moving around it may be
problematic and not clearly documented
but if it came out of the ground in 1800
its acquisition isn't necessarily
driving further looting it's a very
complex and controversial topic but if
it's after 1970 it's supposed to be
prohibited but
some museums still acquire or they bend
the rules or they accept flimsy evidence
for for provenance
but most mostly I'd say it's probably in
private hands or moving to countries
where they have different guidelines
there's no International standard that
everybody has to follow
UNESCO is as close as we've gotten but
all countries haven't ratified that
treaty and they enforce it in unequal
ways
whoa okay so by the way I should add
we're pretty bad about it too it's not a
condemnation of other countries yeah U.S
accepts
looted artifacts sometimes well it can
happen but the other there are two parts
to it first
the UNESCO convention really only
applies to museums it doesn't apply to
individuals within the us they can do
all sorts of private collectors can do
what they want with looted right but
don't we have Global law though to for
for like taking a private uh for taking
a looted artifacts for a private
collection that doesn't matter what's
getting into a very complex area yeah
very briefly up until the 1970s 1980s
looted objects basically couldn't be
prosecuted criminally in U.S courts
because there was no one who had legal
standing to bring a case
there was a Doctrine called the McLean
doctrine that developed after that that
provided some standing for countries
that have nationalized their Antiquities
so if there's a patrimonial law that
says all Antiquities are owned by the
government and we know it came from a
given country then using it using the
national stolen property Act of 1934 as
amended it was possible for those
countries to bring a case in the U.S
court
because we know who it belonged to it
belonged to the government of that
the country but they have to have a very
clear patrimonial law it has to be
evenly enforced and it has to be well
publicized so it only works for some
countries in the same way the U.S never
fully eratified the UNESCO convention it
only already gratified two parts of it
so the only countries that have
protection in the U.S under UNESCO
that this is legal protection are the 18
countries that have signed a bilateral
agreement with the U.S it's not a
memorandum of understanding in place
they're not protected
the ethical guidelines for museums
protect Antiquities from everywhere
based on the UNESCO convention but
legally it's a much narrower standard
wow okay now if now as we as we move
into the current
um director of Museum of Art and
Archeology and director of the Museum of
anthropology at the University of
Missouri Columbia now I love that campus
I've been there before I really like
your campus a lot it's super nice and I
haven't been to the museums yet so I
should I should go check it out
now question maybe one of the first
questions then is
um how many of the artifacts are a
permanent artifact versus like what
percentage would be just transitory they
come in they stay in the exhibit and
then they go to the next Museum that
kind of a thing well we do a certain
number of temporary exhibitions
generally we we consume fewer temporary
exhibitions than we generate so right
now we have two temporary exhibitions on
the road one is an exhibition of work by
the New York artist Simon demigstein and
the other is an exhibition of baskets
from around the country it's the first
big summary show of American basketry
from Native America all the way up to
contemporary fiber artists yeah and both
of those are traveling at the moment in
the past two years the only temporary
exhibition we've brought in is a show
called Electrify which is an exhibition
it's a juried exhibition of art by
emerging young artists with disabilities
and that's traveling nationally
cool okay so so do most
museums have out outbound traveling
exhibitions more than inbound no most
museums actually consume where they
produce reduce okay we do it because
we're poor we don't have the budget to
consume a lot of traveling exhibitions
so we try to put our stuff on the road
and we bring in traveling exhibitions
when we can but most are temporary
exhibitions are in-house using our own
objects we have in the Museum of Art and
Archeology about 16 000 objects in our
permanent collection and maybe three
percent are on display at any one time
sixteen thousand permanent objects right
in art in art and Archeology yeah but
only a small fraction there on display
so the ability to bring out objects for
a temporary exhibition is always there
now how do you pick what with with the
curators in the community how do you all
pick oh well we want objects from 10 000
years ago or one thousand years ago how
does that happen you mean for
acquisition or for a Max uh
let's do four you you you tell you teach
us yeah well for an exhibition
you work with with different
constituencies and figure out what the
overall theme of the exhibition is going
to be and once you've done that then the
individual curator would give shape to
the show like anything else when you do
something by committee you get an awful
lot of good ideas but ultimately you
have to choose a single set of ideas if
you write a paper by committee it's
never quite as good as if the committee
provides input and then one voice puts
it together
the obvious example is the Declaration
of Independence everybody talks about
what should be in it and then Thomas
Jefferson writes it out so it's in one
voice exhibitions are the same way and
the voice of the exhibition is usually
the voice of the curator but the topics
and the themes have been developed in
consultation with other folks okay okay
and then
um in
in and then so then the the the
consultation is there is it like a what
kind of a process I guess is it to to to
consult with everyone to figure out what
uh artifacts are going to be in involved
in
it varies completely by the exhibition
sometimes you're dealing with multiple
faculty members there may be different
communities or or groups within the
community who have specific concerns or
interests sometimes it's temporal so
right now we're in the middle of the
Centennial the end of the first world
war November 11 1918 the guns fall
silent more or less well that's the
topical thing and so we reach out to
different parts of the community and
different institutions the State
Historical Society the libraries
veterans groups all sorts of different
groups what should we do what should we
talk about
sometimes we have those conversations
and it turns out we're not the right
venue and so the exhibition goes
somewhere else and we help another venue
exhibit exhibit it or develop it
sometimes we're the right place and
we'll work with those other partners to
develop an exhibition that involves
their resources as well as our own and
sometimes we just have the consultation
and then we Mount entirely with our own
resources
and so what what now
teach us about what is
some of these sort of realizations that
you've had over the last you know more
than a decade now with the University of
Missouri Columbia what has what have
been some of the
um the sort of like aha moments in terms
of museums and curation
you know
probably the biggest one is that
everything about culture everything
about exhibiting culture is a moving
Target
so what made sense a decade ago might
not today
and we can keep going back and talking
about many of the same problems and
projects Time After Time and they're
always fresh because people are looking
at them in new ways cultural
appropriation is an example is it a bad
thing well it sort of depends if you
look at Japanese wood block prints from
the 19th century they're hugely popular
in Japan and yet they're a very informal
commodity they were made in Mass numbers
they weren't necessarily valued or
preserved in a particular way not
because there wasn't an appreciation of
them but because that's where they were
in the economic system that they were
mass produced and
you replaced them they were constantly
being produced they became prized
collector items in the United States in
Western Europe and influenced whole
generations of artists so the the
Japanese the the idea of taking the
Japanese design aesthetic really takes
off not only in Visual Arts but in
writing Oscar Wilde writes about at the
end of the 19th century there was a
fascination with it and it had a very
pervasive and permanent influence on
Western Art well is that cultural
appropriation and if it is is it good or
bad we generally think of cultural
appropriation as a bad thing but those
are topics we can keep revisiting we're
in the midst of the metoo movement right
now and an obvious example there is you
may have an artist who made a stunning
work of art and yet
they were very flawed human beings
we have that discussion say about the
films of Woody Allen
whatever you think should allegations
about a given film director influence
how we view their work or should their
work stand alone and I don't know the
answer to either the question or for any
given filmmaker or artist if the
allegations are even true but it's an
important question
do you allow your understanding of who
the artist was to influence the way the
work is understood
that's a huge question because a lot of
The Souls of the artists are torn in
some way which makes the art very
beautiful and and so when but then when
you dig at what this how the soul was
torn it can it can set sometimes be a
big turn off for people to enjoy the
work that's a that's a really important
point
so there are lots of topics we can keep
talking about and revisiting and that
was a real learning experience for me I
kind of had the sense that if you've
you've addressed a question
it's hard to come back and address it
again in another exhibition without
audiences thinking well we've already
seen that
and it turns out that a lot of times you
can address the same question in very
different ways and the audience will
respond in different ways our
understanding of it has changed their
understanding of it has changed and
that's an interesting conversation in
its own right yeah
um last last question I'd like to hear
your thoughts about the current state of
humanity and where you think
how you feel about things and how you
feel things are going
I alternate between being very depressed
and very elated
there are outrages every day that fill
the headlines they fill our hearts we
try to deal with them but they just seem
to come faster and faster
that can be very daunting because it
feels like all the bad things in the
world are happening faster and faster
and we can't keep up with them there's
hardly time to mourn for the things
we've lost before we learn of another
thing that we're losing
at the same time we're at the American
anthropological Association meetings and
it's very heartening to see all the ways
anthropology is trying to deal with
those issues
right now the paradise fire has already
claimed more lives than any other fire
in California history and there are more
than a thousand people still missing
all of those fire Crews have
anthropologists embedded with them
trying to help with the recovery of
human remains when Ebola was hitting
parts of Africa
the attempt to slow down the spread of
Ebola really didn't succeed until we
brought anthropologists on board because
the problem wasn't a medical problem it
was a cultural problem of certain
practices that that fostered the spread
of Ebola and once we understood those we
could address them most of the problems
we Face For Better or Worse are cultural
problems global warming is another
example
we think about it as an environmental or
ecological issue but ultimately it's a
cultural issue if it was purely due to
Natural effects we wouldn't need to
worry about that but it's anthropogenic
climate change and if we don't
understand it culturally we can't figure
out how to address it so I'm heartened
by the fact we have so many really smart
colleagues here trying to address that
huge range of issues across all of
humanity I don't know if we can do it
fast enough and I'm not sure everybody's
always listening but if we're open to
evidence-based results I think
anthropology has a lot to contribute to
the answer
that's so well said that we're
news is moving so fast that it makes it
so difficult to
keep up with even the current
what's going on currently but I think
you have the right
you have the right way of of teaching us
about about evidence-based progress in
in society and and I think that you're
right this is a really beautiful place
to
to explore the minds of so many people
that are trying to follow a
evidence-based practice for the progress
of society Alex has been such a pleasure
this has been super nice thank you for
coming on today thank you thank you
thanks everyone for tuning in we greatly
appreciate it we'd love to hear your
thoughts in the comments below check out
Alex's work also in the links in the bio
aaa's links in the bio as well check
them out go and build your dreams into
the world go manifest the future that
you want to live in much love everyone
thank you for tuning in and we'll see
you soon peace